uh see that one more time all right uh  let me just check okay when the game  starts  okay the uh  a little bit of the clock is uh let me  just fix that  it could be real quick to fix this  okay this is the one definitely  all right there we go should we do it  like this a little bit in this like this  all right  okay there we go that should that should  improve on it it's not perfect but it  will it will do nicely  all right so i've lost some  30 seconds uh so it's basically hyper  bullet  uh let's let's try for uh for a sneaky  attack  because otherwise we're just gonna lose  on time  oh that's that's nice i wander the  knight okay there we go  yep that's the good stuff that's a nice  checkmate today  i love it when that actually works  all right uh  that was that was very nice